nearly a month after they disappeared in
a cave in Thailand twelve soccer players
and their coach are going home at a news
conference this morning the boys all
wore their team uniforms as they spoke
about their experience for the first
time the players appear to be healthy
and in good spirits also at the news
conference Thai Navy SEALs involved in
their dramatic rescue Anna Warner is in
Chiang Rai Thailand
Anna good morning well good morning and
as you can see behind me here they are
the twelve soccer players and their
coach here in their first news
conference where they're talking about
their experiences in detail in the cave
there's a person questioning them here
in Thai as you can probably hear when
they first entered the room some people
applauded they had soccer balls right in
front of the stage and so the boys kind
of showed off their soccer moves they
bounced balls in the air
they all look healthy and health
officials say that they are healthy
mentally that they're healthy physically
they're doing well one of the doctors in
the beginning said well you can see how
strong they are they're in high spirits
and they are ready to face what he
called the normal world what we've been
hearing over these minutes now is the
what the kids talking about what it was
like for them for example for the first
night they said they weren't scared that
they wouldn't be found because it was
just the first night you know they kind
of where they were waiting for the water
to go down in the cave and they thought
that by the next day the water would
drop enough so that they could escape so
initially they weren't scared
I think they became more scared over
time and some of them talked about
encouraging the others not to give up
the coach I think was supporting them in
the cave in this but one of the problems
obviously and they were able to get
water that dripped off the cave walls
but they really didn't have any food one
of the kids here one of the younger kids
said that after a couple of days he
started to dream about food about his
favorite foods and that they became very
hungry so what we're hearing so far as
they're giving a very detailed in-depth
description of what it
like for them to be sort of in that cave
in the early moments they had to sort of
climb up onto that high slope within the
cave if you remember the first video
when the British divers found them you
could see they were kind of crouched
into this area a very limited amount of
space kind of on a high slope where they
were able to get out of the water and
they talked about in this news
conference they talked about how excited
they were when the British cave divers
first emerged from the water you could
almost kind of hear it here in their
voices a little bit obviously they're
speaking Thai we're getting an English
translation but you could kind of hear
in their voices how excited they were
and I think it's fair to say that the
room is sort of listening to their every
word people want to hear every detail
this news conference is being broadcast
live across the entire country of
Thailand
on TV and on radio and it's probably
fair to say that most of the people in
Thailand right now I would bet they are
tuned in they are listening to this and
they are hanging on these kids every
word what a great story John thanks for
us so much thanks so much Anna and the
world won't be normal anymore for them
but wow what a story
jesse is remember he was here at the
table the guy who lives life to the
fullest doing all sorts of things says
this may sound crazy but these kids will
look on this years later and say that
was a cool adventure since it turned out
the way it did as a little boy when you
think about it that way you said okay
that's right a life experience so that
nobody else can share that's great